So let's go over the answer to this
or 1 possible answer together.
We're trying to write a program to interpret
if-then-else statements,
and the big concept here about control flow is
that we don't want to execute both the then branch
and also the else branch.
Instead, we'll have to pick one.
So the first think I'm going to do is evaluate
the conditional expression in the same
environment in the same set of evaluations
to variables that we currently have.
If it comes out true, I'll want to execute the then statements.
If it comes out false, I'll want to execute the else statements,
and if you like, this if statement is
the same as one where I checked to see if
the result of evaluating the expression is equal to true,
but if you have a little experience with propositional logic,
that's actually the same as just checking
the value of this variable directly.
So if the conditional expression evaluates to true,
I will evaluate all of the statements in the then branch.
In our running example, that was A and B.
In our current environment there haven't been any intervening
assignment statements so the value of the variables hasn't changed.
Otherwise, if the value of the conditional
expression wasn't true,
presumably it was false, we'll go over here
to the else branch, evaluate the else statements
in the same environment,
and note that no matter what happens,
we're either evaluating the then statements
or the else statements, but not both,
and that decision is made based on the
value of the conditional expression, and that's it.
These 4 lines suffice to evaluate
an if-then-else statement in java script.